[Musique]
nos enfants sont extraordinaires mais
qui parmi vous ne s'est jamais sentis
valorisés à l'école qui parmi vous ne
s'est jamais sentis valorisés à l'école
et même pire s'est déjà senti nul ou bon
à rien je m'appelle christelle brianchon
et je vais vous raconter mon histoire
j'étais en une enfant plutôt sage
sérieuse studieuse c'est comme ça que
j'ai choisi d'attirer l'attention
sage est parfaite je pense avoir plus de
marques d'attention on est dans sage est
parfaite mais il se trouve que ça m'a
rendu invisible
pire ça les fait même plus de temps à
mes profs pour s'occuper de ce qui était
dit turbulent à la fin de ma scolarité
avec mes résultats
on avait de grandes ambitions pour moi
alors je suis allé en maths sup mais les
maths s'était pas fait pour moi alors je
suis allé en médecine mais la mort
s'était pas fait pour moi je suis de
dunes donc sage femme mais les
conditions de travail du système
hospitalier
ce non plus n'était clairement pas fait
pour moi hélas là j'étais arrivé au bout
de ce que le système pouvait me proposer
j'ai donc décidé de créer mon propre
écosystème deux microcrèches dans
lesquels on prend le temps de s'adapter
au rythme de l'enfant mais également à
celui du professionnel
l'humain au coeur de mon travail ça ça
c'était fait pour moi j'ai mis du coeur
dans mon travail est là là j'étais à ma
place mais l'histoire s'arrête pas là
parce qu'en même temps de tout ça j'ai
eu mes deux enfants
et quand elles sont rentrés à l'école
j'ai été totalement effaré par ce fossé
entre la crèche et l'école
voyez en crèche vous explique qu'il faut
respecter le rythme de l'enfant faut pas
le forcer à marcher ou à s'asseoir ça
viendra quand il est prêt c'est lui qui
décide pareil pour l'acquisition de la
propreté c'est encore lui qui décide
ça évite les blocages sa éviter
traumatismes
mais quand il rentre à l'école d'un coup
tout change
on oublie le chapitre sur respect du
rythme de l'enfant ils doivent tous
avoir dessiné un bonhomme à 4 en écran
son prénom à cinq ans lire à 6 ans
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs leur demande même
tous d'aller faire pipi en même temps à
10 heures je sais pas si vous imaginez
avec vos collègues seller le gars ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire quoi les neurosciences ça
fonctionne mais que jusqu'à trois ans
après c'est tous les mêmes
mais vous savez moi j'ai la conviction
qu'on peut mieux faire
j'ai donc décidé de me lancer dans
l'aventuré et créer une école avec une
personne extraordinaire parce que nos
enfants sont extraordinaires regardez
aline amorce à 9 ans elle crée une
sucette brosse à dents elle la vend par
millions brian cela tu as 18 ans et
créer un système de nettoyage des océans
fahim alam
sacré champion de france d'échecs à 11
ans on est toujours surpris de voir à
quel point certains enfants sont
exceptionnelles du qu'on les imagine
comme des exceptions des einstein en
puissance mais je vais vous dire quelque
chose
ces enfants ce ne sont pas des cas à
part ce sont vos enfants ce sont nos
enfants on leur a simplement permis de
développer leurs super pouvoirs
mais c'est pas de la magie c'est
simplement ce pour quoi ils sont faits
et voyez c'est ça le problème c'est que
l'école ne permet pas à nos enfants de
développer leurs super pouvoirs
l'école elle a été créée pour l'ère
industrielle pour travailler dans les
usines mais c'est dépassé ça parce que
elle a même créé des noms pour ceux qui
sont en dehors des normes parce qu'il
dérange hypersensible le haut potentiel
hyperactif les zèbres mais en réalité il
perd sensible
son super pouvoir c'est son quotient
émotionnel surdéveloppé l'hyperactif son
super pouvoir
c'est sa remarquable intelligence
corporelle valoriser plutôt que de
stigmatiser
ça devrait être ça à l'école parce que
quand nos enfants rentrent à l'école ils
sont malléables
ils sont fort ma table alors qu'en école
colle des étiquettes sur eux avec des
élus dont lé turbulente est timide
elle imprime sur eux un peu un peu comme
quand vous enfoncez votre doigt dans une
pâte à modeler ça laisse une empreinte
et plus vous répéter votre geste plus
l'empreinte des profondes et vous voyez
l'école c'est pareil à force de répéter
à vos enfants qu'ils sont lents timide
turbulent elle laisse une empreinte une
cicatrice parfois à nous adultes de voir
à quel point nos enfants sont
exceptionnelles et de transformer cette
cicatrice en emprunte magique
non non tu n'es pas timide tu prends le
temps d'analyser et ça c'est une force
non tu n'es pas turbulent tu
enthousiaste et ça déborde parfois
valoriser leurs forces pour développer
leurs super pouvoirs
ça devrait être ça l'école parce que
quand nos enfants rentrent à l'école
il déborde d'enthousiasmé et c'est ça
c'est ça la clé de leur réussite de leur
bonheur l'enthousiaste avait remarqué à
quel point c'est facile de faire quelque
chose qu'on aime faire
l'enthousiaste l'entousiasme c'est un
moteur et l'école doit l'entretenir
bon vous allez me dire c'est facile
comment on fait ça comment on entretient
enthousiasme à l'école eh bien d'abord
en arrêtant de stigmatiser
en arrêtant de mettre les enfants dans
des cases et en arrêtant de croire qu'il
n'y a qu'un seul modèle d'enfants
compétents chaque enfant à une
singularité un talent et pour le
découvrir il faut prendre le temps de
l'observer s'adapter à son rythme à son
besoin et à son intelligence
c'est comme ça qu'on entretient
l'entousiasme et c'est comme ça que l'
enthousiasme engendre l'efficacité parce
que nos enfants ont tous une
intelligence différentes
d'ailleurs à votre avis combien
existe-t-il d'intelligence différentes
trois quatre cinq peut-être il en existe
neuf et l'école elle n'en reconnaît que
trois là logico mathématique la
linguistique et la visuel spatiale et
tous les enfants dotés d'une autre forme
d'intelligence sont mis de côté par le
système
ils sont invisibles et l'intelligence
corporelle la musicale l'existentiel
l'intra personnel tous ses potentiels en
puissance on a fait quoi
parce que c'est pas qui vous scotche
quand vous regardez incroyable talent
kid
regardez ya pas longtemps zilina
reportage sur un enfant de 6 ans le plus
jeune dj au monde
et bien cet enfant il fait danser plus
de cent mille personnes à ses concerts
intelligence musicale et il a eu la
chance d'être repéré par son entourage
probablement que si on l'avait mis
uniquement sur les bancs de l'école
devant des équations ou une poésie
cet enfant n'aurait rien eu
d'exceptionnel aux yeux du monde
aujourd'hui cette enfance et vibrer des
centaines de milliers de personnes
parce qu'on a repéré son intelligence et
qu'on lui a permis de la développer
parce qu'il est fait pour ça tout
simplement
alors si vous deviez retenir une chose
de mon intervention ce soir c'est que
l'école valorise
un tiers de la population et qu'elle en
sacrifie deux tiers 2/3 qui vont croire
qu'ils sont nuls qui vont être invisible
et ça c'est insupportable
vous voulez rendre votre enfant heureux
regardez et accepter son intelligence
telle qu'elle est
même si ce n'est pas la préférée de
l'école c'est comme ça qu'il deviendra
un adulte épanoui et sûr de lui et si
votre enfant avait une intelligence que
l'école ne reconnaît pas à vous vous
feriez quoi
le monde évolue pourquoi pas l'école je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]